salut tout le monde si vous nous
rejoignez le podcast envergure c'est le
format spécial de cette année ça
s'appelle Victor et les autres émissions
mensuelle lors de laquelle on décortique
le jeu de Victor one banyama on fait un
point sur ses concurrents aussi à la
draft 2023 en NBA le père est mais Hugo
il prenne Lama Victor ce fils dont le
destin d'effraya les gazettes
émission numéro 4 au menu donc on prend
des nouvelles de Victor au début et puis
on se concentre sur sa capacité de base
vous le savez on a un dossier chaque
mois et ce mois de janvier on va revenir
sur le mois de décembre mais surtout on
va se concentrer sur la capacité de
Victor one bagnama à faire des passes
avoir le jeu la technique et aussi ce
qu'il y a dans le cerveau le cuit basket
de quoi il aura besoin pour devenir une
star que cette île que ne s'est-il
encore pas encore faire analyse en
partie 1 partie 2 on parlera d'Anthony
black un beau joueur du côté d'Arkansas
ça s'appelle Victor et les autres enfin
on peut parler des autres
Anthony black qui est attendu top 10 de
cette draft en tout cas dans certains
moques et puis la partie 3 comme
d'habitude on aura des invités
d'habitude c'est un là c'est plusieurs
body en Massa de la SIG Strasbourg il a
posé beaucoup de problèmes à Victor
wembanyama récemment lors de leur
opposition et puis une fois que vous
connaissez bien du côté d'envergure
c'est son coach à la SIG coach dans
romain le roi exceptionnel romain qui
nous expliquera quelle tactique il a mis
en place pour essayer de contrer Wemba
nyama Victor les autres épisodes 4 c'est
parti
[Musique]
avec en invité pour la première partie
ce soir et ça nous fait plaisir parce
que ça fait plusieurs années qu'on bosse
avec la First Steam et Thomas Dufont
accepté notre invitation pour ce soir en
plus ils suivent la grande majorité des
matchs de Wemba nyama avec avec la First
steam en direct de Boulogne Levallois
comment ça va Thomas impeccable avec
salut à tous les gars ravi d'être parmi
vous pour parler du phénomène il y a
plein de choses à dire non seulement on
les suit mais on a la chance de les
commenter sur twitch donc on suit ça de
près Victor son évolution bien sûr et de
tout ce qu'il y a à côté avec la belle
qualité vidéo qui va avec qui était pas
forcément au rendez-vous au parrain
l'idée partait un peu de là on avait
envie de bien produire les matchs donc
on a pris un peu de risques financiers
pour produire tout ça mais pour
l'instant le résultat est plutôt cool
donc il y a plein de choses à dire sur
le joueur victoire victoire mais aussi
sur sur le phénomène plus globalement
donc c'est cool c'est cool d'en parler
ensemble bah ouais merci encore une fois
d'être avec nous et puis côté enversure
et bien nous avons une doublette
composée de Mathias arrivé cette saison
dans l'équipe suis la haine NCA alors
plutôt axé Big Ten du côté de notre data
team mais forcément cette année on a
tous un oeil sur la bête pique élite
quand même comment vas-tu Mathias salut
salut ça va ça va impeccable
ça va impeccable du côté du nord de la
France et
en banlieue parisienne nous avons notre
twitcher celui qui anime les lives
twitch tous les vendredis soir 21h pour
ceux qui connaissent pas le rendez-vous
quand même live twitch envergure c'est
notre Google notre Hugue de Al comment
vas-tu mon Hugues ça va très très bien
être avec vous ce soir vous m'avez
manqué messieurs vous m'avez manqué
c'est clair ça fait longtemps ça fait
longtemps
bon comme d'hab messieurs on s'y jette
on commence par l'actu le dernier
épisode de Victor et les autres c'était
juste après la défaite à Roanne alors on
en avait parlé lors du dernier épisode
on disait que Victor était pas forcément
à 100% à l'époque etc on va revenir sur
ce mois assez rapidement mais Tom sur le
sur les derniers matchs qu'est-ce que tu
retiens un petit peu de Victor au global
un peu plus en difficulté quand même il
fait un gros match face à Monaco puis
ensuite c'est un peu plus compliqué
ouais c'est c'est marrant parce que il
nous a tellement impressionné sur la
série la des 30 points
consécutifs que je me demande quels sont
les attentes en fait autour de lui bon
elles sont très très hautes bien sûr
mais tu vois on est en train de dire
qu'il est un peu en difficulté un peu en
difficulté j'ai envie de dire que oui il
est un peu plus en difficulté parce
qu'avant il était sur un nuage total
mais ce qu'il arrive à produire même
dans les matchs où il manque d'adresse
où il manque de confiance on va parler
de certains matchs tu la chance de
commenter le match contre Cholet je peux
vous dire que dès l'échauffement
des dans sa routine puis ensuite dans le
match sur la quasi-totalité du match
sera plus de trois cartons il est pas du
tout dedans dans dans l'adresse dans le
toucher tout ce qui nous a bluffé
pendant les premières semaines de cette
saison et bien n'était pas là tous les
shoot à lui et avec la planche des
chutes en feuille de ouais mais il est
raté il faisait des écarts de ouf donc
j'ai envie de te dire qu'il est plus en
difficulté mais il n'empêche que quand
tu regardes à la fin les stats bon bah
elle est toujours dans des strates qui
n'ont aucun sens vous êtes à plus de 20
points des rebonds et de l'influence
surtout de l'impact sur son équipe et
sur et sur le résultat donc je te
rejoins un petit peu un peu en
difficulté mais qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire pour un joueur qui reste dans des
standards hyper élevés d'un point de vue
des statistiques individuelles et des
résultats collectifs mine de rien bien
sûr il compense cette maladresse par un
impact sur les défenses adverses qui est
pas toujours quantifiable ou en tout cas
il faudrait des stats avancées qu'on a
pas forcément sur le championnat de
France et par ce qu'on peut regarder
c'est tout simplement
les lancer francs tenter c'est à dire
que même si tu es maladroit au tire et
bah tu vas sur la ligne tu vas chercher
tes points sur la ligne et sur le moi
enfin sur les quatre derniers matchs en
fait depuis la dernière émission il est
à 23 sur 24 relance
ça fait silence et francs par match
c'est pas mal
Mathias qu'est-ce que tu as retenu des
matchs que récents que tu as vu de
Victor au-delà du passing dont on
parlera plus tard
ben moi j'avais pas eu l'occasion encore
de regarder vraiment en détail les
matchs de Victor depuis le début de la
saison donc là pour l'émission c'était
l'occasion de le faire et bon
ça ça confirme les highlights que je
pouvais voir c'est
c'est toujours impressionnant de le voir
jouer alors je l'ai vu plus en
difficulté je l'ai vu
meilleur mais bon globalement très
impressionné par par le profil taille
handle et shotmaking quoi
bah oui c'est marrant d'avoir la
première impression parce que toi tu
avais pas encore eu le temps de le
regarder c'est vrai que j'ai sollicité
pour le podcast et du coup tu as eu ta
ton premier flash quoi comme le premier
shot de Victor one banana ça fait ça
fait de l'effet quoi
ces matchs donc pour les cités on a à
domicile contre Monaco à Paris à
domicile contre Cholet et à Strasbourg
je sais pas lesquels tu as vu parmi les
quatre mais voilà qu'est-ce que tu as
qu'est-ce que tu as retenu qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce qui a retenu ton attention
de pouvoir suivre des
parce que alors je l'avais découvert
effectivement avec le la compétition
internationale mais je l'avais vu très
jeune vu que je suis en banlieue tu vois
donc moi je l'ai vu de Nanterre je l'ai
vu à zel et là la Boulogne donc je vois
un joueur grandir physiquement aussi
de plus en plus en confiance qui se
rapproche aussi du panier moi j'avais
j'avais peur c'était chez le joueur que
un mec trop en périphérique qui arrive
pas à aller au Cercle alors il est
toujours beaucoup en périphérie
j'aime bien j'aime bien son aisance de
jeu j'aime bien sa fluidité j'aime bien
que lui maintenant soit parfois un
mentor pour ses coéquipiers c'est plus
petit jeune tu vois je trouve qu'il est
de plus en plus en confiance dans cette
équipe des mètres 92 et
après faut aussi remarquer qu'il a eu
des changements de coéquipier avec alors
je sais pas si c'était blessure
pendant deux mois et demi au moins ouais
voilà qui était sur le qui était sur le
bas cours un profil plus défensif là je
joue avec Thomas Besson donc plus exposé
parfois sur les pick and roll pick and
pop
non excusez-moi on l'a vu contre
Strasbourg ou Hugo a pris a pris la
sauce individuellement et donc il y
avait beaucoup d'espace derrière donc
voilà j'aime bien j'aime bien
l'évolution de Victor and banyama j'aime
bien son son application et euh il y a
de l'excitation alors j'ai toujours
envie de le voir plus rebondir j'ai
toujours envie plus impliqué vers
l'avant mais quand même quelle évolution
depuis les espoirs de Nanterre
c'est clair que qu'on est tous assez
impressionné mais il y a un secteur
particulièrement quand même qui a
impressionné les observateurs pas
seulement français mais étrangers qu'on
a reçu dans les premiers épisodes tout
le monde a dit
je savais qui savait shooter Victor one
Mania moi je savais qu'il était grand
qu'il avait une mobilité incroyable que
défensivement c'était un truc qu'on
avait peut-être jamais vu mais par
contre je m'attendais pas à ce qu'il
passe là-bas aussi bien alors c'est
notre dossier du soir
comment qu'est-ce qui reste à faire pour
pour Victor on va faire un diagnostic du
passing de Victor one bagnama parce que
bah c'est c'est une grosse partie de son
jeu
aujourd'hui et c'est sans doute amené à
le devenir avec le rôle qui sera le sien
en NBA en tout cas s'il veut atteindre
les sommets à un moment donné il va
falloir qu'il soit un bon voir un très
bon passeur dans l'actu je mentionne
quand même rapidement
qui vient d'avoir 19 ans et qui elle a
été élu MVP du hall Star Game on s'en
fout il a reconnu lui-même que c'était
du marketing de la Ligue donc là
ensuite dans le vesti
le soir même il était très content très
content que Victor le lui offre il était
pas obligé donc je l'aurais pas fait
mais en tout cas dans dans l'imaginaire
collectif c'est des petits moments qui
qui marquent voilà pour par rapport à
son état d'esprit aussi c'est vrai que
c'est beau gestes et
je sais plus qui nous avait raconté
c'est Pascal giberney qui nous avait
raconté cette anecdote Victor one bagnat
quand il sent qu'il mérite pas des
compliments il aime pas en avoir il
racontait une anecdote de quand il était
en jeûne et qu'il avait fait un tournant
en Espagne et tout le monde tout le
monde était là à lui taper dans le dos à
lui dire BRAVO BRAVO et quand il était
revenu il avait dit bah tout le monde
m'a dit bravo alors que j'ai joué comme
une merde je ça m'a pas plu quoi donc je
vous invite à écouter l'épisode avec
Pascal évidemment c'était le dernier
mais ça en dit beaucoup sur l'état
d'esprit passons passons du coup au
passing Hugues juste pour commencer là
dessus avec un truc que tu aimes au
passing chez Victor je sais que tu en as
relevé plusieurs mais le truc qui t'a un
peu tac sauté au nez quoi
dans la paillette et la strass j'aime
beaucoup ces touch je passe c'est c'est
petit passe en une touche de balle qui
va avoir après un rebond offensif qui va
avoir dans dans l'instantané quand c'est
pas quelque chose de mis en place de
créer et il arrive par sa longueur par
sa hauteur par son instinct de jeu à
trouver juste des petites remises
toujours très très propre pour un mec
dans le Dunkin spot pour un pour un
joueur en transition etc donc voilà
j'aime beaucoup l'instant qui est là je
trouve meilleur passeur quand il est pas
dans quelque chose de réfléchi de
mécanique ce qu'on lui demande assez peu
mais qu'il est dans l'improvisation de
jeu et
ça j'aime beaucoup tiens c'est pas un
mec qui va forcément prendre le robot
enfin s'il fait vouloir remonter tout de
suite il peut juste petite claquette la
passe et puis il va trouver un
coéquipier ouvert donc voilà bah c'est
c'est ce côté un peu fantaisie chez le
joueur et qu'il le rend qu'il leur rend
imprévisible qui leur a encore plus beau
qu'il ne l'est et voilà qui fait qui
fait les petits à l'aide qui fait kiffer
donc on se rappellera des touches à la
fin de sa carrière cerveau adaptatif
aussi ça veut dire ça veut dire que
quand je prends le rebond je suis pas
fixé sur ce qui va se passer après je
vois le gars PAF
il y a une très il y a une grosse
rapidité entre le cerveau et l'acte de
la main côté technique Mathias assez
simplement mais quand on quand on scat
on fait ça
est-ce que tu il y a des choses
techniquesment que tu as vu Victor ferme
ou ne pas faire je te dis passer à une
main utiliser ces deux mains sur ses
passes à une main voilà est-ce qu'il y a
des choses que que tu l'as tu ne l'as
pas vu faire ou tu doutes encore un peu
de sa capacité à le faire juste
techniquement
beaucoup de passes simples main droite à
une main au dessus de l'épaule pas ça
demain j'ai le je crois que je l'ai
jamais vu faire une passe main gauche
je pense qu'il a encore pas mal de
progrès à faire sur la main gauche sinon
j'ai pas vu non plus de pas ça et fait
c'est encore des j'ai vu des passes
vraiment très simple pas compliqué mais
toujours dans dans
la bonne décision
sur des kicks passent ou des choses
comme ça mais j'ai pas vu une énorme
technique en tout cas personnellement
et sur la précision du coup tu parlais
du timing qui était bon sur la précision
le timingway je le trouve un petit peu
lent à ce qu'on a prise de décision en
fait ah ouais
mais pas en fait j'ai l'impression que
quand il a vu déjà
quand il a eu le temps de scanner un peu
le terrain avant
il y a pas de problème mais dès qu'il
est emprisé à deux enfin qu'il est pris
par plusieurs défenseurs je trouve qu'il
a un petit peu de mal à trouver la
solution et le coéquiper des marquer
donc voilà mais après c'est un peu du
chipotage mais je trouve qu'il y a prise
de décision encore un peu lente non mais
encore une fois mais tu as raison c'est
du chipotage mais encore une fois on a
un prospect générationnel
évidemment on coupe les cheveux en 4
parce que c'est ce qui va faire la
différence entre un All-Star et un all
of Heimer peut-être tu vois donc c'est
pour ça et vu que ce sont les
projections c'est pour ça qu'on le fait
Tom tu avais un truc à dire je crois que
c'était
super dur sur
sur les passes il fait des passes
simples bien sûr mais il a aussi des
gènes gamme de passe difficile par
rapport à son poste par rapport à sa
taille et par rapport à ce qu'on attend
d'un mec comme ça moi je honnêtement il
m'a bluffé bien sûr surtout l'aspect de
l'adresse
sur la taille sur sa vélocité et tout ça
mais dans la passe je l'ai déjà vu faire
en étant au stade des choses qu'un grand
ne fait absolument jamais ou alors c'est
Nicolas et au kitsch donc un grand ne
fait jamais donc j'ai vu tenter il y a
eu des skis passent dès demain vraiment
j'envoie des deux mains
des passes bien senti c'est vrai que les
touches basses tu as raison de dire ça
vu que c'est c'est des trucs qu'on adore
c'est des trucs même de petits encore
une fois de le passer sur le robot
offensif mais je l'ai vu tenter des
passes entre les jambes de mecs des
passes un peu aveugle sur le mec qui
coupe alors je te dis pas que c'est des
passes ultra difficile je te dis que peu
de grands tentes ce genre de passe il en
a déjà vachement
côté réussit aussi il y a des pertes de
balle ici et là ça fait partie du jeu
mais le potentiel qu'il a sur la qualité
de passe avant d'aller sur des passes
simples que te donne la défense bah je
la trouve déjà hyper élevé pour un mec
de son âge et encore avec ses en
ajoutant ces qualités physiques ou en
tout cas où c'est des fois physiques
pour ce type de d'action sur internet il
y a une créativité alors après Mathias
je t'ai lancé sur le sur le le chipotage
évidemment pour que tu décortiques un
petit peu comme ça est-ce que tu as tu
as du
une passe qui t'a qui t'a plu du du
positif des une face tu t'es dit tiens
celle-là il y a pas grand monde qui l'a
fait
je crois que je vais être obligé de
rejoindre Hugues les touch passe c'est
vrai que il y a un match je sais plus
quand contre qui c'est il en a fait au
moins trois dans le match et c'est vrai
qu'elles sont toujours bien senti sont
toujours très efficaces
d'autres types de passes qui t'avaient
plus il me semble ce qu'on a parlé avant
quand même on prépare un petit peu mine
de rien
il y a plusieurs situations
quand toi tu as Thomas il parlait de
Nicolas yokitsch c'est un secteur où on
a assez peu exploité Victor cette année
encore c'est le position de poste haut
dans des situations de hand of et il a
des séquences où il est comme ça de au
cercle et il arrive très bien tu vois
sur une fin de hand of le joueur cut
dans le dos finalement il l'a pas sa
demain dans son dos donc il y a quand
même une certaine effectivement
créativité il y a il y a un goût pour le
risque alors des fois ça fait perdre de
balle mais c'est un jeune joueur qui qui
se fait kiffer et puis quand on parlait
de fois de
tu vois de tu disais sur des prises à
deux il manque de lecture de jeu je
pense qu'il a aussi ce truc où il veut
se correr et quand il veut se correr bah
il peut s'enfermer là-dedans et forcer
un tir etc mais encore une fois c'est un
très très jeune joueur et il y a du
développement pour les autres types de
passe j'aime beaucoup cette passe
et on a parlé la passe une main droite
par dessus l'épaule c'est une passe qui
ressemble presque un ou que c'est une
presse car son presque un bras roulé ou
tu te demandes s'il peut se correr parce
qu'il peut se correr mais il rabat le
ballon pour trouver soit un joueur dans
le dunk in spot soit kicker avec déjà un
peu de manipulation visuelle on a
l'impression qu'il va être dans le dans
le tir et puis d'un coup avec un geste
de poignet assez sec il peut la rabattre
pour trouver un shooter dans les corners
donc ça c'est un geste qui maîtrise bien
et je trouve qu'il a progressé sur ce
secteur là dans le dans le short troll
avant c'était des passes assez statique
qui faisait puis maintenant ils
récupèrent le ballon et tout de suite il
peut partir vers l'avant et cliquer sur
le corner avec cette passe et puis dans
les autres dans l'autre secteur un
secteur que je assez peu parce que je
trouve que Victor est encore un peu en
retrait dans le dans le rebond défensif
les passes que j'appelle les passes à la
Kévin love que killing Love est
excellemment bien je prends le rebond et
puis je t'envoie une passe de quoi
torback à travers tout le terrain pour
des mecs qui courent on a un joueur qui
a la capacité de récupérer la balle et
de porter le ballon jusqu'à la ligne à
trois points mais on a un mec aussi qui
peut lancer les coéquipiers donc quand
tu joues avec des gros athlètes et des
dragster comme il peut avoir du côté de
Boulogne c'est aussi très efficace donc
je pense que au niveau supérieur ça on
va voir plus parce que il aura plus de
responsabilités au rebond que dans cette
équipe de Boulogne à mes yeux et donc on
va avoir des des grosses transitions
menées où il va envoyer le ballon à
travers et les mecs qui vont courir
surtout sur une équipe je pense qui va
être assez mauvaise au début puisque
c'est une équipe qui tank et ils ont
très très vite tu vois Houston par
exemple il s'éclaterait là-dedans où on
court tous vers l'avant comme des comme
des demeurer mais on le fait avec
beaucoup d'énergie et Jerry win qui
remonte porteur junior etc donc voilà un
point que fixer la passe après rebond
profitons Emmanuel
vers la question que je voulais poser à
Tom qui est quand même parmi nous celui
qui sans doute regarde le plus de NBA
pour toi de quoi il aura besoin dans son
bagage technique à la passe par rapport
au rôle qu'on va lui assigner en fait tu
l'imagines dans quel rôle et qu'est-ce
que qu'est-ce qu'il aura besoin de faire
pour réussir dans ce rôle là
c'est une bonne question ça s'évaste là
dans dans les premiers mots qu'on a dit
on est allé beaucoup sur la technique et
c'est normal mais je crois que on oublie
quelque chose de d'évident quand on
parle de passe c'est la sensation du
joueur à faire des passes quand le jeu
demande de faire une passe et c'est vrai
que Victor est tellement forte sachant
que que quand il a décidé de tirer ou
qu'il a décidé de jouer pour lui on va
en général il va tirer mais je l'ai vu
très souvent chercher des passes même
dans des temps forts pour lui des
moments où il est chaud chercher des
passes pour faire briller les autres je
parle pas de la passe pour faire une
passe décisive je passe de la base parce
que le jeu va te le demander donc une
eau qui passe ou il passe dans le jeu en
tout cas sans forcer sur un contrat et
quand je me projette sur ce le joueur
NBA qu'il va être donc sur un terrain
plus grand avec beaucoup plus d'espace
avec des joueurs plus forts aussi
forcément moi je l'imagine être un
joueur d'abord post-up dominant donc si
tes dominant sur post-up il y aura
forcément des prises à deux il y aurait
une lecture à avoir sur ce type d'action
qui qu'on peut qualifier de simples si
tu as un cui de basket assez élevé c'est
le cas mais il y aura aussi pourquoi pas
toute cette toute cette
comment dire ce cet endroit sur le
terrain à la yukić en tête de raquette
on le voit pas du tout du tout du tout
dans ces positions là aujourd'hui avec
des mecs qui coupent etc ou en tout cas
qui qui vont jouer ovball pour lui
offrir des ouvertures et je crois que
ces deux
situations
seront des situations où Victor va
d'abord exceller d'ici quelques années
et qui vont lui permettre d'avoir une
moyenne de passe
franchement haute moi je l'imagine dans
quelques années être en NBA au moins 5
passes de moi il y a donc et c'est des
situations assez simples faciles à
travailler le shortroll il y en aura de
temps en temps enfin il y aurait
énormément mais il est tellement plus
que qu'un mec qui pose un pic et qui
ouvre qu'en fait il y aura beaucoup
d'autres situations sur lequel il aura
de lecture assez simple entre guillemets
à faire et donc il pourra produire plein
de possibilités
Mathias t'imagine toi des situations sur
lesquelles on pourrait on pourrait le
projeter en NBA pour pour conclure sur
sur ce passing
sur du short roll sur du pick and pop
sur sur de l'ISO voilà après le rêve
c'est toujours de voir quelque chose
ressembler à du Heidi
mais
ouais façon il y a une
tellement d'options envisageable avec
Victor et c'est ça qui est vraiment
intéressant quoi Tom je sais que même
nous on n'aime pas trop les comparaisons
mais est-ce que on peut le comparer dans
ce domaine de la passe avec un gars
comme kidi ouais mais en fait qui a dit
c'est en fait le j'avais raison de
d'aller les gars sur Kaidi parce que
c'est peut-être la meilleure comparaison
possible un scorer filiforme mais qui en
fait est tellement en bon basketteur va
avoir tous ces autres compartiments du
jeu qui vont évoluer naturellement qui
dit ça fait des années qu'il est assez
haut dans les en moyenne de pas décisif
donc je dis quand je dis oh c'est à
partir de 5
parce qu'il est tellement fort qu'en
fait il y a beaucoup d'ouverture qui
vont s'offrir à lui pour faire des
passes simples qui est 10 personnes
valser on va le citer parmi les
meilleurs passeurs de NBA mais en fait
la défense est tellement focus sur lui
que forcément il va y avoir des
ouvertures je crois que Victor il a pas
besoin d'être un excellent passeur
pour créer des passes difficiles s'il
réussit à
ouvrir dans les bons timing à faire la
passe dans les bonsmis à ses coéquipiers
naturellement naturellement ce sera un
bon passeur de NBA voire un passeur de
très haut niveau pour son poste et puis
vaut à 5 passes
et puis comme tu comme tu disais vu
qu'il a déjà l'état d'esprit pour le
faire c'est c'est normalement pas
quelque chose qui devrait qui devrait
être un problème est-ce que vous le
ressentez aussi ce quand tu parles
d'état d'esprit ce truc de d'avoir quand
même envie de faire jouer les autres
ouais c'est ça non bien sûr mais c'est
aussi être un leader impliquer les
autres ça veut dire se mettre dans des
conditions optimales pour aller chercher
la victoire normalement donc
effectivement c'est c'est intéressant
on va clore cette partie 1 et on va te
laisser
à tes multiples casquettes Tom
c'est gentil merci d'être passé à vous
parlez les autres
évidemment
je sais même j'ai même pas la peine de
te faire la promo je pense que les gens
qui écoutent envers
stimulent l'inverse c'est pas forcément
vrai mais depuis des années donc oui oui
mais voilà on connaît on connaît vos
rendez-vous c'est quasiment en continu
la force team c'est il y a pas que du
basket en plus on essaye on a justement
le prochain match de Victor contre
Fos-sur-Mer
donc ce sera l'occasion de voir si
Victor continue de progresser sur son
passing game et ben c'est parfait merci
beaucoup Tom merci les amis merci merci
à plus ciao
on va parler des autres on va parler
d'Anthony bleu
[Applaudissements]
alors Mathias je te donne la parole pour
me faire un petit portrait d'Anthony
black une fiche d'identité pour les gens
qui connaissent pas c'est qui ce joueur
qu'est-ce qu'il fait sur un terrain
voilà qu'est-ce qui se passe avec lui
alors Anthony black c'est une recrue 5
étoiles
qui joue à Arkansas
donc on est sur un sur un Guard oversize
qui a pas toujours été Guard il a
beaucoup joué
profil très playmaker très bon passeur
très bon connecteur
pas pas vraiment un bon jump shooter
mais très bon playmaker vont défenseur
très versatile
athlète plus que plus honnête
donc pas mal de trucs qui font un peu
saliver quoi et un bon début de saison
du coup et un bon début de saison dans
une équipe d'Arkansas qui alterne le bon
et le moins bon et dans une équipe dans
laquelle il est il est titulaire surtout
en profitant de l'absence de l'autre
recrue star de l'équipe Nyx Miss donc il
en profite parfaitement pour l'instant
Hugues c'est quoi son juste son ticket
d'entrée en NBA en fait juste c'est quoi
son argument de vente qu'on va voir
tourner sur ispn alors on va avoir le
classique shit maintenant qu'on a tout
le temps c'est
il est grand il est polyvalent et porte
le ballon donc les gens ils vont acheter
très très haut maintenant quand tu fais
plus de 2 mètres et que tu peux dribbler
passer défendre plusieurs positions
complètement moderne donc on va aller
là-dessus sur un sur un joueur de
transition il va y avoir peut-être des
fantasmes de créateurs principal
créateur secondaire à son détaillera un
peu plus après ça grossisse s'accrochent
va devoir décider mais voilà le côté
effectivement très grand je porte le
ballon je prends le rebond je peux mener
une transition et je peux en théorie
défendre plusieurs positions c'est c'est
dans la norme actuelle et beaucoup de
joueurs sont très haut de rareté juste
pour ces critères là
Mathias c'est marrant Hugh il a dit
qu'il peut passer qui peut défendre qui
veut dribbler mais il a pas dit shooter
est-ce que c'est est-ce que ce serait
pas un peu le laqué le point
d'interrogation de d'Antony black
c'est c'est la grande question et la clé
de sa pro NBA
pour l'instant
tir pour l'instant un bon pourcentage
enfin bon pourcentage il doit être
autour des
36%, une mécanique
comment dire
tu peux dire dégueulasse
bon voilà
pas vraiment de
diversité dans le shoot il y a pas
vraiment de pull-up il y a pas de tirant
en mouvement il y a pas de migraine mais
tout de même je trouve que c'est un très
bon finisseur au cercle
mais voilà sinon c'est pas c'est pas
c'est pas un shooter quoi après on a vu
des joueurs qui réussissent bien NBA qui
à l'époque avait le même profil et un
shoot pas très beau je pense je pense à
Josh Guigui aujourd'hui mais il y en a
d'autres il y a d'autres exemples
l'important c'est aussi le volume au
bout d'un moment
Hugues tu projettes tout Anthony black
dans cette classe pour donner un peu une
idée aux auditeurs évidemment on
rentrera plus dans le détail j'explique
mais on aura des portraits qui
rentreront dans le détail on fera un
truc 30 minutes Anthony black spécifique
là c'est juste pour vous présenter un
peu des gars qui seront dans la même
classe que Victor bon peut-être que tu
l'as entendu à mon temps depuis le début
je suis pas son plus grand fan j'étais
très très amoureux du joueur à la sortie
de son tournoi américain parce qu'il a
joué avec alors je sais plus si c'est
les U18
qui ont démoli la compétition américaine
avec camoodmorro
on va dire que parmi les meneurs de jeux
de cette classe de draft qui joue ainsi
et n'a pas énormément je vais la voir
moi derrière un mai comme challenge qui
fino qui joue une Diana donc on va être
sur à mes yeux peut-être plus de la fin
de loterie je vais pas la voir dans mes
dans mes deux premiers tiers
parce que des il y a un joueur pour le
coup donc je viens de parler là enfin je
vais dévoquer le nom qui fait tout mieux
que lui dans tous les secteurs de jeux
donc forcément il patient à mes yeux de
la comparaison
par rapport à son compère de sa classe
de draft freshman aussi
Mathias est-ce que tu tu valides la
projection de Hugues ou est-ce que toi
tu le vois peut-être un peu plus haut ou
un peu plus bas moi je pense que je
l'aurais parfois je le réparer fin de
loterie vaut mieux au mieux au bord du
Top 10 mais pas pas plus je pense pas ok
donc Anthony black Arkansas
prospect évidemment à suivre pour pour
cette cuvée 2023 de la draft 2023
évidemment vous renvoie vers notre site
pour avoir au moins la fiche d'identité
la tête de ce monsieur et puis et puis
évidemment suivez nos tous nos analyses
sur Twitter de temps en temps les Hugues
les Matias les tomates où vont vous
balancer du petit tweet pour vous
informer quand il y a de la belle paire
ou des évolutions intéressantes
messieurs je vais vous laisser puisqu'on
va faire la dernière partie la merci
merci Mathias
merci Hugues
[Musique]
à plus les gars et tout de suite c'est
la partie 3 avec nos invités très
spéciaux
troisième partie de ce podcast envergure
donc d'habitude on l'a fait en anglais
mais là on va la faire en français et
puis on vous mettra les sous-titres
après pour pour la partie anglaise on a
deux invités d'habitude on a qu'un là on
a deux parce que c'est beau
parce que on voulait avoir quelqu'un qui
a joué face à Victor onmanyamak a connu
un mois décembre pas si simple notamment
parce que il y a eu ce match face à SIG
Strasbourg le 26 décembre victoire de la
SIG et le match up c'était un certain
bodium Massa et qui est avec nous
bonsoir bonsoir salut beaudien salut
merci de d'avoir fait appel à moi et ça
va être un plaisir de pouvoir te
raconter tout ça
bah oui c'est le tout le plaisir est
pour nous et donc pour nous donner un
peu les coulisses aussi de de ce match
on a en plus celui que vous connaissez
l'assistant de la SIG Romain Leroy
romain comment vas-tu ça va donc
supporte dans la journée maintenant il
fait de l'extra sur les podcasts c'est
bien
c'est ça
on va faire en sorte que ça dure le
moins de temps possible pour
dans moins de 12 heures on se voit si tu
veux donc je vais courte je vais
écourter le temps au maximum
bon match match
up face à Victor web benyama alors on va
pas éventer les secrets de la
préparation de match mais quand même ce
qui m'intéresse de votre part à vous
deux et je vais poser d'abord la
question à toi d'audience
quelle consigne spécifique tu peux tu
peux nous dévoiler que tu as face à
Victor one byama en gros qu'est-ce qu'on
me dit par rapport à ce matchup avant le
match elle est comment la préparation
par rapport à un matchup plus classique
enfin c'est un pivot plus classique
déjà je pense que
toute personne sait que c'est pas une
personne entre guillemets classique
sans manquer de respect à tous les
autres joueurs c'est pas une personne
classique parce qu'il fait quand même il
a assez grand il fait 2m21 il a 2 m 30
d'envergure il est capable de chuter à 3
points et tout donc je pense que
[Musique]
la préparation de match comme tu as pu
le dire elle était totalement différente
et une consigne qu'on a pu nous donner
je pense et d'essayer de lui faire
prendre un maximum de tir à
bas pourcentage ce qui nous aurait
permis je pense et du coup je pense
qu'il nous a permis de le mettre un peu
plus en difficulté et de générer un peu
plus de frustration de de son côté et
aussi de frustration aussi du côté de
ces coéquipiers alors une fois qu'on me
dit ça c'est comme on dit c'est plus
facile à dire qu'à faire c'est à dire
toi comment tu fais sur le terrain
vraiment tu peux rentrer dans le
technique il y a pas de problème comment
tu fais sur le terrain au niveau de
l'activité des mains des orientations
des pieds de la distance avec
l'attaquant pour pour lui faire prendre
justement ces tirs à bas pourcentage
déjà j'ai la chance j'ai la chance de
pouvoir bien quand même bien d'avoir une
bonne latéralité défensive de pouvoir
quand même bien me déplacer
du coup ce qui me permettait de pas être
trop en retard à chaque fois sur ces
dribbles j'ai été je crois une ou deux
fois mais en faisant tous ces dribbles
je pense qu'il m'a rarement il m'a
rarement passé en dribble et aussi
j'ai ma taille qui m'a permis je pense
de gêner un maximum après ce qu'il faut
savoir aussi c'est que Victor est très
grand et une très grande envergure c'est
à dire que même quelqu'un qui fait 2
mètres 8 10 comme moins il va le gêner
mais ça va pas être ça va pas être
énorme donc je pense avec mon activité
parce que j'ai aussi beaucoup
d'activités en défense et j'y mets
beaucoup de cœur en défense parfois même
un peu trop ça m'a permis ça m'a permis
d'être à chaque fois assez proche de lui
même au début du match je pense que je
me suis un peu oublié en défense sur
quelques actions parce que on a eu
beaucoup de de Drive dans la raquette
j'étais assez concentré sur lui et ça ça
je vais pas dire ça a permis ça m'a
permis de le faire sortir de son match
parce que il fait quand même un match
extraordinaire extraordinaire malgré
tout en termes de statistiques mais ça
m'a permis de réduire son pourtant 100%
tâche déchire
romain est-ce que la consigne avant le
match c'est de un peu moins aider sur
Victor comment tactiquement on met en
place une rencontre face à un gars qui
qui a des qualités que personne d'autre
n'a dans le championnat de France alors
en fait on avait un plan B je vais pas
rentrer trop dans le détail mais je suis
sur le plan a volonté c'est ce que c'est
ce que dit c'est ce que dit beau c'est à
dire que on voulait faire en sorte
qu'ils prennent des tirs qui soient le
plus compliqué possible à avoir de façon
à faire baisser le pourcentage du joueur
parce que c'est un joueur d'exception
donc inévitablement faire des choses un
peu exceptionnelles on a regardé un peu
ce qu'on fait les autres avant nous
Monaco avait pris cette option là aussi
Roanne avait pris une option un peu
différente mais qui rejoignait cet axe
là Monaco par exemple la pas mal défendu
avec avec un 3 4 assez mobile assez
actif plus en plus de John Brown avec
blossom game et John Brown avec les deux
et ça nous a donné les idées clairement
parce que c'est un joueur qu'il faut il
faut défendre dans l'intensité donc on
était vraiment sur sur cette axe là et
surtout en fait l'idée c'est un petit
peu leitmotique de ce qu'on fait
défensivement c'est de ne pas laisser le
joueur intérieur attraper la balle
facilement et surtout une fois qu'il a
ne pas lui laisser le temps de lire
Victor est pas un mauvais passeur donc
derrière si en plus on laisse lire après
une réception facile on se met en
difficulté et c'est là où le travail de
bonne viande notamment était très
important et précieux parce que c'est un
joueur qu'il faut toujours avoir
toujours joué avec intensité toujours
être face à lui essayer de cadre au
maximum lui forcer à poser la balle au
sol et elle à le tenir dans les petits
espaces parce qu'il a malgré tout besoin
d'amplitude parce qu'il a il a
latéralité la verticalité et plus on
amplitude à ces joueurs là plus c'est
compliqué
et donc toi quand tu quand tu quand tu
prépares les joueurs très spécifiquement
quand tu fais ton ton scooting des
adversaires avant le match
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que tu dis
est-ce que est-ce que il y a des
préférences enfin est-ce que tu dis par
exemple
il vaut mieux qu'il arrive sur sa main
droite avant de tirer je dis un exemple
au hasard peut-être pas ça mais tu vois
est-ce qu'il y a des gens de consignes
qui existent pour Victor bon ça existe
pour un peu tous les joueurs je vais pas
te mentir je vais regarder ce qu'on
avait choisi pour lui
l'idée c'était ce que ce que je t'ai dit
principalement c'était pas d'attraper de
balles facile et pas d'attraper de balle
avec un temps pour lire standing catch
is tu sais c'est le fait de pouvoir
attraperia on était vraiment là-dessus
et vraiment ne pas donner le temps de
lecture et dans l'intensité c'est
clairement ce qu'on a ce qu'on a ce
qu'on a écrit sur sur quoi faire en
défense et par contre de l'autre côté du
terrain décision rapide face à lui parce
que malgré tout faut essayer de tenir de
tenir compte du fait que il a une très
très bonne latéralité pour un joueur de
sa taille mais malgré tout il faut
bouger et l'implication qu'on a eu aussi
en défense pour essayer de le faire
défendre certaines situations et aussi
des clés donc
globalement on a ciblé un petit peu les
deux côtés du terrain avec avec ce qu'on
peut faire toute façon encore une fois
c'est un joueur d'exception mais on se
rend compte qu'il y a des petites choses
qu'on peut encore exploiter par rapport
à lui à notre niveau
donc ça veut dire qu'on préfère être
peut-être trop près de lui quand il
attrape la balle quitte à faire un peu
passer sur le premier pas mais au moins
pas lui laisser le temps comme tu dis de
lire plutôt que que de en gros on
préfère lui ouvrir peut-être un dribble
ou deux plutôt que que du laisser la
possibilité de tirer ou de prendre une
bonne décision l'idée c'était vraiment
d'être en miroir par rapport à la balle
c'est à dire toujours une main dessus et
en fait je pense que c'est après c'est
bon c'est c'est beau qui était sur le
terrain donc il expliquera sûrement
mieux que moi mais l'idée ces joueurs là
je pense qu'il faut toujours être en
trouver le panier et le cadrer le plus
possible plus tu donnes d'angle plus
c'est compliqué après derrière alors que
tant que tu arrives à rester de face
à partir un joueur de cette taille là tu
restes de face comme il a besoin
d'amplitude si tu es face à lui que tu
cadres il peut pas franchir s'il peut
pas franchir il gagne pas le duel si tu
commences à mettre de l'orientation
c'est plus compliqué mais c'est encore
une fois je préfère laisser Thibault
répondent par rapport à ça pour moi qui
est défendue je suis en Victor me
maniamas c'est c'est
justement monsieur Massa
quand tu rentres sur le terrain vraiment
dans les faits premier duel quel
consigne tu as en tête et quels sont tes
priorités vraiment dans ton dans ton
cerveau d'athlète de se dire il faut que
je sois là là qui quelle est ta priorité
sur le le premier le deuxième duel avec
avec
mon duel avec Victor il commence avant
avant le match déjà parce que il
commence pour moi on va dire entre
guillemets en début de saison quand tu
vois que Victor il fait chaque weekend
des statistiques phénoménales du coup tu
dis un jour un jour ou l'autre ça va
finalement finir par m'arriver
maintenant le premier duel ben forcément
je sais que
j'ai été en
j'étais avec Vincent Collet le coach
en équipe de France je suis quelqu'un
qui fait quand même
un peu beaucoup de fautes donc je me dis
que le premier duel forcément et je suis
on a on a un problème de d'intérieur à
ce niveau là donc je me dis peut-être
que le premier duel il va être pour
Victor match de Noël ça le plein ils
vont sûrement à la télé ils vont essayer
de te donner la balle est-ce que je fais
tout simplement c'est je crois qu'il
attrape la balle à trois points moi je
suis face à lui je mets mon bras je
défends et il rate son tir donc à partir
de là
je me dis
même si j'ai juste j'ai juste mis mon
bras il a raté son tir je me dis ah ça
m'a donné de la confiance directement en
fait ça m'a donné de la confiance je me
suis dit ben il a raté son premier tir
j'ai fait une bonne j'ai pour moi
j'avais fait une bonne défense même si
elle était anodine mais je me suis dit
que j'ai fait une bonne défense donc du
coup ça m'a donné de la confiance et je
me suis dit ben ouais je peux je peux
défendre et après de l'autre côté en
attaque je vois que j'arrive quand même
à avoir des solutions mine de rien on
arrive quand même avoir des solutions en
attaque parce que jusqu'à présent il a
mis beaucoup de contre il prend l'espace
et là sur ce match là en attaque on
arrivait quand même avoir des solutions
et on avait quand même de l'espace dans
la raquette donc au final au fur et à
mesure ça a fait que j'ai pris confiance
en moi et ben une fois que tu es en
confiance
tout tout entre guillemets tout tout
peut arriver et tout d'un côté tout va
dans ton sens entre guillemets
et du coup après sur sur les les matchs
où il va justement plus plus driver que
shooter etc que est-ce que tu réagissais
différemment que sur
un autre duel que tu aurais eu dans la
saison et et comment tu réagissais
différemment en fait quels étaient tes
attitudes je parle vraiment physiquement
tu as bien expliqué le mental mais
vraiment physiquement je sais que
enfin je sais je connais pas exactement
tout ces manières de jouer mais en ayant
regardé un peu jouer Victor c'est quand
même une personne par rapport à certains
joueurs sur mon poste c'est pas une
personne qui va prendre la balle post-up
et qui va essayer d'enfoncer en dessous
du panier je sais qu'il est malgré tout
quand même assez se retourner ou alors
s'il a un peu plus loin il va prendre la
balle il va dribbler puis il va shooter
3 points il fait rarement prendre la
balle enfoncer un joueur donc je savais
que dans ce cas là à chaque fois qu'il
allait prendre la balle peut-être deux
paniers un peu plus loin que que la
raquette je savais que ça allait être il
allait se mettre face à moi il a laissé
de de dribbler entre les jambes où il a
laissé dribbler face à moi et moi comme
j'ai pu le dire en début de de de
podcast malgré tout j'ai quand même une
bonne latéralité donc ça fait que je
crois que une fois il est passé ligne de
fond et c'est ce que disait romain en
fait avec Victor c'est que lorsqu'il
passe ligne de fond lorsqu'on a plus des
appuis en face de lui lorsqu'on est plus
face à lui
il est tellement long que en fait le
fait qu'il doit le fait qu'il saute et
qui tente ses bras il est quasi au
panier du coup il a il a réussi à
provoquer une faute comme ça et le fait
de rester face à lui à chaque fois je me
disais bon déjà il faut que tu restes
face à lui et un maximum ne pas le
coller parce que c'est se jeter un peu à
l'abattoir être gardé une distance de
bras et puis après réfléchir quoi qu'il
arrive il fait 2m21 que tu que tu fasses
2 Medis ou que tu sois plus petit il
réussira quand même à tirer mais essayez
de le gêner un maximum et puis en gênant
forcément ça va le mettre dans une
situation inconfortable en essayant de
faire prendre des tirs forcés ça va
mettre ça va mettre son équipe aussi
dans une situation inconfortable et de
l'autre côté ben on attaque comme il a
dit romain on a on a réussi à le mettre
plusieurs fois en danger donc
sur ce match là
Victor il shoute à 33%. ça lui arrive
bah c'est tout simplement
le deuxième score le plus bas de la
saison et encore le premier c'était
c'était face à Pau il avait joué que 20
minutes etc
à 6 sur 18 comment toi tu as senti
vraiment sur le terrain qui réagissait
face à cette situation de difficulté
c'était aller son troisième match
au-dessous des 40 %, alors qu'avant il
marchait sur l'eau pendant pendant
7-8 matchs il marche sur l'eau quoi
comment il réagit face justement à une
adversité qu'il a du mal à surmonter
même si comme tu l'as dit il fait des
superstats mais il est pas à droite je
trouvais qu'il était quand même assez
serein dans le sens où mine de rien il
raconte cher il continue à reprendre un
autre il reprend un autre tir ça te
dérange pas et au final à la fin on voit
bien qu'on a failli on a quasi failli
perdre le match sur il met un tir je
crois à 1 m derrière la ligne c'est moi
qui défend là-bas elle est montée
limites au plafond de du regnus et il
fait ficelle et surtout mine de rien il
fait il a il a pas un super pourcentage
mais
au final il a pas douté et je le vois
sur ces lancers parce que il fait quand
même je crois 14 sur 14
il fait 12 sur 12 alors que
peut-être que un joueur qui qui
douterait il aurait raté un ou deux tir
il arrive au lancer il en aurait
peut-être laissé filer trois qui serait
9 sur 12 ça serait quand même ça serait
quand même bien pour un intérieur même
voir exceptionnel ou énorme mais là il
fait 12 sur 12 donc il a pas forcément
douté même si au final il y a un peu de
frustration parce que après du coup tu
forces un peu plus les les actions
il y a plusieurs petites choses là que
que 10 books sont intéressante la
première c'est moi j'arrive dans la
salle 1h10 avant quand les mecs sont
l'échauffement c'est déjà un cirque
incroyable il y a du monde ça prend des
photos et compagnies et tu sens qu'il y
a aucun moment le joueur il est impacté
négativement par le Cirque qu'il y a
autour
c'est alors que je pense que quand ça
arrive toutes les semaines comme ça et
encore chez nous c'est assez calme c'est
le plus compliqué en termes de
disponibilité pour le public etc etc ça
déjà il le gère et beaucoup de sérénité
ensuite
sans mettre de comment dire de son
nuancer la victoire qu'on a qu'on a
contre Levallois sans rabaisser la
qualité de la victoire qu'on a contre
Levallois il joue trois jours avant
contre Cholet et c'est pas forcément une
équipe sur son rythme de saison
contrairement à nous à d'autres clubs
qui sont européens qui sont habitués à
jouer tous les deux trois jours
c'est un paramètre également à prendre
en compte après derrière il a beau être
un petit peu
en de ça au niveau adresse sur le banc à
2 minutes de la fin on n'est pas serein
malgré tout parce que même si on est
montable du stress ou plus 15
quand il commence à se mettre en route
on imagine déjà l'article dans la presse
le lendemain ou ben en deux minutes il a
retourné le truc et voilà parce que
quand il commence à être le premier tir
il redonne de la confiance tout de suite
à tout le monde et il doute pas et ce
que dit bonniant le dernier point qui
est super important joueur intérieur A21
qui a pas d'enfiler des perles quand il
est sur une des lancé ça a pas assez de
l'argent à la banque
parce que il entend 12 et il y a et en
face il y a pas forcément la volonté de
de maillocher c'est juste que il les
provoque parce que ouais alors après ça
c'est un autre débat parce qu'il y a
aussi une très légèrement suétude sur
certaines actions où il y a le statut
qui parle et ça c'est voilà c'est c'est
autre chose je pense que nous c'est
peut-être un petit peu beaucoup mais
voilà après derrière le joueur crée le
statut aussi et le contexte
par la suite le statut
c'est pour ça que ça moi je le remets
pas en question c'est que je n'y lance
pas la victoire mais il y a aussi des
facteurs qui expliquent à un moment
le joueur il peut pas non plus être à
être exceptionnel toutes les semaines et
malgré tout bon il finit à 20 26 18 je
crois que nous c'est ça
un chantier quand même
ça fait un petit chantier beaudion on
parle souvent enfin pas on parce que
nous on sait quand même faire la part
des choses et c'est pas un joueur qui
joue pas forcément toujours près du
cercle mais
le rebond est pas toujours cité comme
une qualité de Victor tu l'as trouvé
comment dans ce domaine c'était comment
la lutte face à lui pour pour le rebond
il y a un prix 18 après
c'est vrai que par rapport à certains
par rapport à certains joueurs c'est
vrai que c'est pas
c'est pas un mordu on va dire entre
guillemets c'est pas quelqu'un qui va se
battre forcément pour aller récupérer le
rebond il est pas dans le fight mais il
a cette qualité d'être il a ce don même
je dirais d'être grand qui lui permet
malgré tout même si il est pas dans le
fight et de pouvoir récupérer
9 rebonds par mois parce que je crois
qu'il doit être à 10
rebond par match et
malgré tout ben c'est quand même un don
et il en profite quoi
il utilise très bien sa longueur en fait
il a des segments qui font qui il a pas
besoin c'est pas un joueur qui est dans
le combat au sol nécessairement d'une
part parce que le c'est pas du tout son
truc et puis c'est pas il a pas encore
le volume physique pour je pense aussi
même si la énormément évolué il a du
très bien bosser cette année encore
parce que je trouve que physiquement il
évolue c'est c'est ça que c'est visible
de moins en moins par contre il a il a
pour lui le fait d'avoir donc la
longueur et un timing ce qui fait que
sur l'air bons of notamment s'il est
s'il est s'il est pas trop loin sur un
mois c'est c'est c'est claquettes à
chaque fois donc donc à ça après leur
bon def il protège le cercle
suffisamment
et la balle bah quoi il fait de vin donc
la balle va les retomber dans les mains
au moins un autre mais parce que
l'immodion c'est vrai c'est pas c'est
pas un joueur de combat c'est pas un
joueur au sol les aisément par contre il
y a il y a des qualités athlétiques et
physiques et dans la lecture à la
compréhension aussi des trajectoires sur
sur si on a sur l'anticipation qui font
qui va compenser le le fight qu'il aura
peut-être un peu moins que d'autres ou
la capacité à aller au charbon qui dort
un petit peu moins que d'autres mais
c'est pas quelqu'un qui n'aime pas le
pain c'est pas quelqu'un qui aime pas le
contact c'est pas quelqu'un qui va le
fuir en fait c'est juste un joueur qui
est très en finesse et qui n'a pas
besoin aujourd'hui de
d'être dans le fait de cogner dans la
dureté pour obtenir quelque chose ou
pour aller chercher quelque chose je
sais pas si je le fais bien comprendre
tout à fait
l'audience ma dernière ma dernière
question c'est à propos de un peu de
l'état d'esprit mais telle heure tu as
dit il était serein mais comment ça se
passe sur le terrain est-ce que est-ce
que c'est un gars qui ouvre sa gueule
qui trache qui trache tolk un peu est-ce
que c'est est-ce que c'est un joueur qui
parle que assez coéquipier ce qui quelle
attitude il a avec son environnement en
fait en général est-ce qu'il est
complètement dans sa bulle ou est-ce
qu'il est comme tout le monde non après
bon déjà j'étais super concentré dans le
match
concentrer sur sur tout tout ce qui tout
ce qui pouvait faire après je suis aussi
pas un joueur de trashtalk donc je l'ai
pas forcément vu trash talker et puis
euh
dans ce match là ça a été assez
compliqué pour Levallois parce que on a
pris assez tôt l'avantage avec un gros
écart donc et il était pas dans dans son
meilleur match mais après pour l'avoir
côtoyer un peu en fenêtre équipe de
France c'est quand même quelqu'un qui
qui se mélange qui discute qui joue avec
tout le monde qui est qui va parler
après bien sûr il a il a il a je sais
pas s'il a encore s'il a 18 ans je crois
qu'il va faire il vient d'avoir 19 il
vient d'avoir 19 je crois que c'était
hier ou cette chanson de Adidas
c'est quelqu'un que j'ai trouvé de de
super mature parce que il avait il avait
quand même des connaissances il disait
il avait l'air il avait l'air posé en
fait il avait l'air d'avoir la tête sur
les épaules et pas
pas en mode ouais moi je vais alors NBA
ou je sais que tout le monde vous est
nul etc il parle avec tout le monde et
pourtant il connaît son il sait le
statut qu'il a et il se mélange et c'est
et franchement c'est assez cool de voir
un joueur comme ça
est-ce que tu as est-ce que tu as une
anecdote sur ce match est-ce que
apparemment tout le monde t'en parle
depuis 15 jours est-ce que tu as un truc
que tu racontes à chaque fois où est-ce
que est-ce qu'on est-ce qu'on a dit
l'essentiel franchement j'ai une
anecdote mais à mon avis c'est Romain
qui a du cas du cas du vous dire ça mais
c'est pas mon anecdote mais depuis ce
match depuis ce match là j'ai
l'impression que je viens de
d'arriver dans le basket en fait
j'ai vu des tweets de commenter de
personnes d'autres journaux disant ouais
les gens sont venus voir ils ont
découvert bodiamassa alors que pourtant
mon match en soit défensivement c'est
vrai que j'ai fait un match complet
offensivement il y a encore des choses à
encore des choses à améliorer mais j'ai
l'impression que que je venais de de
commencer le basket d'arriver en LNB en
fait et pour l'anecdote même ça
d'ailleurs au moins au passage il est
pas au courant mais pour l'anecdote la
veille du match franchement je fais que
de penser au je fais que penser à mon
match c'est à dire que je suis chez moi
je suis posé avant d'aller dormir je me
dis demain ça va être Victor demain ça
va être Victor fais attention demain ça
va être Victor parce qu'en plus comme je
t'ai dit je sais que le match est
diffusé sur BeIn Sport c'est à dire que
là faut pas LNB TV en mode ouais le
serveur il marche pas on n'a pas pu voir
ton match tranquille là une balle perdue
en passant on aime c'est bien non
je vais arriver dans votre championnat
donc
c'est là il y a tout le monde qui va
regarder tout le monde à BeIn Sport tout
le monde connaît Victor ou Emmanuel
Macron c'est match ils sont sur l'équipe
ça veut dire que tout le monde va être
au courant de ce qui va se passer la
sieste d'avant match avant de dormir
pareil c'est à dire j'essaie de me poser
dans mon lit j'essaie d'imaginer de
visualiser mon match donc c'est à dire
que si il fait comme ça tu essaie de
défendre comme ça en attaque s'il se
passe comme ça d'abord tu défends comme
ça d'abord tu tu te mets dans cette
situation tu vois comment comment
comment il répond et moi j'avais déjà
prévu enfin entre guillemets ça remet
aussi d'ailleurs il est pas grand mais
moi j'avais pendant le match je m'étais
dit avant le match je m'étais dit
j'avais prévenu quelques de mes
coéquipiers j'avais dit les gars le truc
avec Victor je pense et je pense que
c'est ce qu'a fait Roanne si je me
trompe c'est d'essayer de lui donner le
moins de temps d'adaptation en attaque
c'est à dire que si Victor au début du
match il commence à enchaîner à se dire
ben peut-être j'ai mis trois points sur
beaudotes 6 puis 9
je pense qu'il il va rouler par contre
au début il a beau dire moi ça qui est
sur lui qui fait 2 mètres 10 qui
défendent cette manière là il a appris
Léopold cavalière qui défendu une autre
manière puis après la Rogers curux ainsi
de suite et ben là ça va lui laisser
moins de temps d'adaptation et puis ben
au final
il aura il aura soit une prise de
décision rapide et tant mieux si il
marque et si si ça fonctionne et bien ça
sera tant mieux pour nous donc pour la
petite anecdote voilà c'est juste que
entre la veille et le jour du match j'ai
j'ai beaucoup pensé à lui à mon avis
c'est la première fois je pensais autant
à une personne avant de jouer contre
cette personne
et c'est bien normal et je pense que ça
va être ça pour
pas mal d'adversaires dans sa carrière
donc
tu ouvres la voix mais c'est vrai que
toi ta première saison pro lui devait
être en U13 quoi donc les gens ont
peut-être
il faisait déjà plus d'un mètre 90
mais effectivement tu t'étais là tu
étais là avant lui quoi donc les gens
découvert baudomasal les gens qui
connaissaient pas trop le basket
français il y a pas de il y a pas de mal
à ça
mais voilà bah merci beaucoup pour pour
ton témoignage l'audience romain t'as un
truc à ajouter sur le match j'étais
entendu être assez impressionné par le
côté savoir rester dans sa bulle qui est
important qu'on est un joueur de cette
un joueur un joueur un joueur de très
haut niveau déjà je pense que c'est ce
que dit beau c'est c'est vrai il faut le
réaliser c'est des joueurs comme ça
c'est c'est énorme de pouvoir les voir
les croiser les jouer et puis je pense
que les affronter sur le terrain ça doit
être encore quelque chose de de de plus
de plus intéressant le plus
impressionnant dans une carrière ça va
être des moments quand même quand même à
vivre quoi donc c'est moi le fait de
l'avoir vu en activité sachant que moi
j'avais commencé
avoir un oeil un peu dessus quand il
était eu 14 j'ai eu des vidéos du camp
national à l'époque il est fait avec un
an d'avance ça fait quelques années que
je le vois jouer qu'on en parle un peu
entre nous bah là on rend du réel oui
c'est clairement l'extraterrestre mais
moi j'aime le j'aime la colle le côté
stabilité qu'il a dans l'attitude dans
le comportement le fait qu'il montre
très peu de frustration sur le terrain
ou alors c'est c'est jamais vraiment
marqué et ce que ce que dit beau tout à
l'heure on a vu il y a pas si longtemps
que ça de la part de certains prospects
qui ont prédé des grandes carrières des
comportements parfois plus gênants
là ça bouge pas c'est-à-dire qu'il suit
son chemin et est-ce que ce que tu dis
beau par rapport à l'attitude du joueur
en contexte l'équipe de France ou en
tant que coéquipier je suis pas surpris
parce que c'est ce qui dégage donc
c'est voilà c'est le paquet le paquet
est complet et puis
à devoir où est-ce qu'il va atterrir et
puis où est-ce qu'il sera dans deux
trois ans surtout ça
merci à vous deux merci à vous deux
d'avoir
accepté témoigner pour
cet épisode 4 de Victor et les autres
merci bodyan souhaite plein d'autres
matchs positifs du coup maintenant que
les gens te connaissent
merci à vous en tout cas de de
m'avoir sondé pour pour ce petit cette
petite émission et du coup comme tu as
dit ben ouais je me souhaite et je nous
souhaite à moi et Romain de plein
d'autres matchs positifs et de continuer
notre petite remontada au classement
quoi bon romain on se retrouve très très
bientôt
on va pas divulgacher mais il y a une
petite surprise en préparation du côté
de d'envergure sur un petit épisode
rétro
merci à tous de nous avoir écoutés
c'était Victor et les autres épisodes 4
à retrouver évidemment sur notre site
envergure.co toutes les plateformes sur
Youtube abonnez-vous partout mettez-nous
des bonnes notes et allez encourager la
s'ils sont de passage près de chez vous
ciao tout le monde